when you i mean look you go from a kid
who's uh you know an overweight kid who
uh you know suddenly gets this
confidence
uh supposedly i read about is it true
that your your brother
you you found a hundred bucks under a
video game and you took that you went to
the gym with it is that true
i did yeah i did but hey i got to back
you up a little bit because
um even when i was a the fat kid i still
had the confidence
you know so it was uh an unusual
combination i had the uh
denver pyle said uh
i had the strength of my ignorance
you know i i didn't know it was
impossible
so i did it i think it's important it's
like it's nice to see that
you sort of knew who you were then in a
way you know where i
i'm still figuring it out but like you
were like i don't care and that's what i
like to say
you know i have family members or
friends that you know are overweight or
or don't like this about themselves i
don't like things about myself but i'm
like
just learn to love yourself i mean
that's what we have to all do
and you see it seems like you had
confidence in yourself and you
loved yourself and you're ready to go to
the next level well i believe
michael that we're here for some reason
you know we aren't just we aren't just
around uh we aren't just taking up space
um that there is something we're
supposed to do
everybody not just me not just you but
everybody
and i think my grandmother put that
instilled that into me
um and that's a lot of that
i think i passed on in a very real sense
to in in smallville jonathan to clark
you know you're here for something um
so do it so you're not here to be a
failure you're not here to be a uh
a problem you're here to do something
good
for someone else and
i knew that so as a as a kid i knew
well yeah i'm overweight and i i did
have to make a decision which my brother
helped me make
my brother one day after my like third
slice of pizza at six flags said
so i guess you've just forgotten all
about that movie star thing huh
and i said boom what do you mean they
said well how many fat
movie stars do you know and at that
point all i could think of was zero
mostel and i
i knew i wasn't made to be zero mostel
john candy john belushi well not at that
point this was uh
i don't know i don't think uh saturday
night live happened in 76
75 sure maybe think so so i
when you're on a path and you hear
somebody tell you
the truth that will
steer you in the right direction
[Music]
uh you recognize it again that's that
opportunity recognizing that opportunity
so i had the opportunity to either
continue eating the pizza
or stop because he was right
uh but who i was up to that point was
the fat
kid who made up for not being able to
run in track
by having a guitar on my back and
playing music
for everybody all the time in high
school so i wasn't an unpopular guy i
was kind of that guy with a guitar that
would would sing those
jim croche songs um but that stopped as
soon as my brother said that that
stopped the next day
we were at a bowling alley and i was
playing the uh an evil knievel
pinball machine i dropped a quarter
i crawled underneath the machine to get
the quarter and i found a hundred dollar
bill
across the street it sounds like it
sounds like fiction
across the street from the bowling alley
was a big sign
nautilus had just opened up the first
nautilus i think anywhere
and it was three years for a hundred
dollars
so i that night i asked my mom you know
what should i do and she said well if
you're really gonna
do this movie star thing then
you should spend your hundred dollars so
i did i spent my hundred dollars
and uh two months later i was uh 185
pounds and looked great
uh because i'd spent two months dieting
and working out at nautilus
uh the next uh couple months later i was
one of the hardest trainers at nautilus
there in sandy springs so it's it's this
is like this is a movie
the first act this is the first act
where the kid goes and he
picks up the quarter and he sees a
hundred dollar bill and his boo is like
i don't know what should i do with it
well you want to be a movie star don't
you
he's like well yeah but i could buy a
lot of pizza and a lot of
other cool things with this it's like
okay i guess you're not gonna be a movie
star
and then he looks across the street and
there's a freaking gym
and after three years and the kid goes
there which most kids won't ever go
they won't do that i wouldn't have done
that i would take 100 bucks i would have
bought a colecovision
i would have bought whatever and and i
just i i don't have that you
that's amazing
you